[Music]
all right welcome to hannity busy
breaking news night disturbing news from
afghanistan four dangerous gitmo
detainees released by obama and biden in
2014. they have now been appointed to
key positions in the new islamic emirate
known as afghanistan great job joe and
barack they joined several other notable
terrorists at the top of the taliban's
new government now these radical
islamists are holding our fellow
americans hostage blocking them from
leaving the country sending death squads
door-to-door hunting for anyone that
helped america that has western ties in
the last 20 years but tonight the biden
administration they are more concerned
with the taliban's lack of inclusivity i
wish i was kidding but i am not it's day
25 americans abandoned behind enemy
lines and held
hostage with regard to the composition
of this uh government or or interim
government it includes
uh people who have uh very challenging
track records
allowing the taliban to pick its most
wanted its top draft picks out of
guantanamo to now see them in charge of
what is quickly becoming a terrorist
super state is just a slap in the face
so i guess we shouldn't be surprised
when now terrorists people have been let
go and everything else are running the
very organization that this state
department and this administration is
trying to negotiate with it makes
absolutely no sense
every time i don't think this situation
can get any worse it does americans held
hostage abandoned behind enemy lines day
25
25 days americans held hostage abandoned
behind enemy lines let me say this one
more time
all of this could have been prevented
easily from april to may from may to
june to july to august we had months to
withdraw all of our people
we had a duty to halt we saw the taliban
advancing we could have easily
maintained control of bagram air base we
could have aggressively bombed the
taliban with drones and we could have
expedited the withdrawal of americans
and their families and also our afghan
allies and the billion dollars plus
worth billions of dollars worth of
military equipment
while we had full control
biden was warned daily by the intel
community about the deteriorating
situation he chose to lie to this
country lie to all of us about the
well-trained afghan military they were
all getting their asses kicked and the
entire world was watching and of course
he encouraged afghanistan's president
the one that abandoned the country with
a lot of money to lie to the world and
now the fate of our fellow americans
rests in the hands of terrorists
including islamists once imprisoned at
guantanamo bay freed in exchange for a
former army deserter
by biden and obama in 2015 during his
announcement speech then candidate trump
predicted that this bergdahl taliban
prison swap he predicted it would end in
a disaster just like years earlier he
predicted osama bin laden was a bad guy
that wasn't going to end well take a
look
the people negotiating it don't have a
clue
our president doesn't have a clue he's a
bad negotiator he's the one that did
bergdahl we get bergdahl they get five
killer terrorists that everybody wanted
over there we get bergdorf we get a
traitor we get a no-good traitor
and they get the five people that they
wanted for years and those people are
now back on the battlefield trying to
kill us
now donald trump was right two years
later beau bergdahl he pleaded guilty to
desertion and misbehavior before the
enemy and now four out of the five gitmo
detainees who are exchanged for bergdahl
they are in leadership positions now
atop the new taliban government which by
the way will swear themselves in i
believe on the 20th anniversary of
september 11 2001. and as we first
reported last night these terrorists are
blocking private chartered flights
from extracting our own american
citizens and according to biden's own
secretary of state tony blinken our
ability to get those planes in the sky
is pretty pretty limited without the
control of an airport or boots on the
ground watch this
as of now
the taliban are not permitting the
charter flights to depart
they claim that some of the passengers
do not have the required documentation
while there are limits to what we can do
without personnel on the ground without
an airport with normal security
procedures in place
we are working to do everything in our
power to support those flights
and to get them off the ground
and the state department said that even
if those private chartered planes get
permission to land in a country they
can't come to the u.s that's not an
option how is that possible when we have
u.s citizens on board but if they get
permission but that permission is
predicated on permission from our state
department the answer will be no explain
that to me biden said we had all the
leverage
where's the leverage joe if only we held
on to bagram or kept forces on the
ground or used predator drones to push
back the taliban
were speeding up the withdrawal until
every american was out every afghan ally
was out all our military equipment was
out none of that happened you had months
watching this unfold and now blinking
seems less concerned with americans left
behind but he's more concerned with the
lack get this the lack of diversity and
inclusion in the taliban's new
government when the taliban was in power
the last time girls couldn't go to
school women couldn't go to work they
were subjugated to men young girls were
taken as sex slaves and wives by taliban
fighters do we think they changed i
doubt it take a look
yesterday the taliban named a new
interim government
we're assessing the announcement but
despite professing that a new government
would be inclusive
the announced list of names consists
exclusively of individuals or members of
the taliban or their close associates
and no women it certainly does not meet
the test of inclusivity
and it includes
people who
have
very challenging track records
a stunning lack of inclusivity from the
terrorist organization that we already
know enslaves women subjugates women and
forces young girls against their will to
marry taliban fighters and they murder
musicians and artists and anybody they
don't like does that make sense these
are terrorists mr blinken how stupid are
you
they're they're whipping women and
children with wires at the airport
they're hunting down female afghan
police officers they're murdering them
right in the street you see the reports
you know the truth they helped plan the
9 11 terrorist attacks that took out
nearly 3 000 americans
2977 if my memory serves me correctly
the binding administration is worried
over the lack of gender diversity in the
taliban's new government
are you really that ignorant
sadly it appears the answer is yes a
brand new ad from trump's save america
pack highlights the insane level of
incompetence really just touches the
surface take a look how did president
biden get this so wrong they clearly
have the capacity to sustain the
government in place this has been a
disaster the taliban is not the south of
the north vietnamese army it looks like
saigon
2.0 to me the likelihood there's going
to be
the taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely this tragedy was completely
preventable
we told you joe biden was not up to the
job now we're seeing the devastating
consequences of his incompetence biden
vacationed while afghanistan collapsed
american military equipment was
plundered and now america weeps over the
live sacrifice due to biden's surrender
and joe biden was still telling us one
of the best trained armies in the world
one of the best trained militaries in
the world
after the taliban had the afghan
military army in full collapse and had
taken over 60 percent of the country how
do you get it that wrong when you know
it's wrong maybe it has something to do
with this steep cognitive decline joe
biden seems to have a hard time speaking
thinking walking and doing any basic
function at this point for himself so is
staff of social justice warriors they
seem to be calling the shots but don't
take my word for it just look at this
other strange moment from biden earlier
today take a look
now i'm supposed to stop and walk out of
the room here i'm going to stop but with
your permission i'm going to walk into
the room because i want to say hello
thank you
[Applause]
and i know we don't call them tornadoes
anymore either it stopped being funny a
long time ago now hundreds of americans
are held hostage 13 brave american
heroes are dead because of that guy's
incompetence one gold star mother
invited former president trump to her
son's funeral not joe biden you have all
these 9 families saying don't come to
our memorials on 9 11. and this mother
says that joe biden has blood on his
hands in a social media post she called
biden a weak human being and a traitor
joe biden truly is a weak human being in
every way physically mentally morally
and now a vast majority of americans
seem to agree a new democratic-leaning
yougov economist poll has biden's
approval rating now below 40 percent
with an over sampling of democrats of 10
percent hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else